hello I'm Dan Moreau host of Summer
Movie report on screen junkies plus and
this is my spoiler view of Independence
Day resurgence the aliens are back and
if you don't want to be spoiled you can
read my non-spoiler review right now on
screen junkies com so last warning this
isn't one of those mild spoiler reviews
with the spoiler tag on it just because
I don't want people to get upset I am
gonna spoil the snot out of this movie
so if you don't want to be spoiled tune
out now otherwise let's get to the
review they like to get the landmarks
it's Independence Day resurgence a
terrible movie yes it is but is
Independence Day resurgence a good movie
yes it is I don't know what to think
about this movie I go back and forth on
it there's some stupid some of the
stupidest dumbest most ridiculous things
I've ever seen in any movie that made me
roll my eyes so hard are in Independence
Day resurgence but some of the things
I've been dreaming up for 20 years some
of the things that I always wished a
sequel to Independence Day would deliver
are also in this movie this is a
terrible movie this is also a great
movie I don't know what to make in this
movie so let's break it down that's why
we do these spoiler reviews because I
don't know what to think about
Independence Day resurgence so beyond
the alien destruction the special
effects the strongest part of the first
Independence Day was the cast and yes a
lot of people say that that movie is
cheesy but the thing that you have to
grant the first Independence Day was
that the characters were well drawn you
knew their relationships to each other
and the best part of this movie are the
returning characters from the first
movie
now let's of course start off with Jeff
Goldblum who comes back as David
Levinson he was great in Independence
Day and the thing I love about Jeff
Goldblum is as weird and odd and crazy
as he was in 1996 he is twice as weird
and odd and crazy in 2016 it's like he's
getting his dialogue read to him in his
ear as he goes and then he's surprised
by what he's just been told and you can
tell in his performance
I love how weird he is I love that weird
energy that it brings to his performance
and of course the thing that could have
really taken this movie over the top and
that it was missing was Will Smith I
don't get why Will Smith passed on the
movie but more than that I don't get why
they made this movie without Will Smith
Will Smith is missed so much in this
movie they needed that charisma they
needed that star power but there is this
weird moment where his son goes to the
White House and there's like a
six-foot-tall oil painting of him
hanging on the wall it's kind of worth
him not being in the movie for that
moment because why I just want to go to
a white house where there's a oil
painting of Will Smith hanging on the
wall I hope somebody takes that oil
painting from the movie and Commission's
it because I will frame it and hang it
in my house this is one of the weirdest
moments in this movie and that's one of
the things about this movie is even the
bad stuff the bad stuff is so weird that
you
I have to respect it but also hate it at
the same time this is a strange strange
movie also returning is Bill Pullman as
president Whitmore now I like the tact
that they took with this character I
like the fact that the people that had
the aliens inside their head from the
first movie are kind of traumatized and
that when the aliens return that that
kind of screws them up a little bit and
they go a little batty but the movie
kept setting him up and then it just
kind of lets him down at the end like
there's this scene in the hangar where
he shows up and he starts talking and
people start gathering around them and
he's making the speech he's like there's
a reason why we fought this war in 1996
it's because we believed in each other
and people start looking at each other
or nodding I'm like oh hell yeah Pullman
is about to kick it into gear we're
about to get another we will not go into
the night we will not vanish without a
fight and then it just kind of ends and
he's like and that's because we love
each other and that's it it's like wow I
thought you were setting me up for
another speech and you don't it just
goes to the next scene but the biggest
part was at the end of the movie he
shaves the beard he gets back in the
fighter pilot outfit he's flying those
cold fusion bombs into the alien ship
where the Queen is that moment when he
looked at that Queen in the eye and said
from the people of Earth happy fourth of
July that should have been the greatest
moment in cinema history people should
have been ripping the chairs out of the
theater and that that was an al be back
that was an isil Avista baby moment that
was ten times better than Randy Quaid's
hello boys I'm back from the first movie
but you can't really hear it it's really
said really weakly and it doesn't even
work he blows up the bombs he sacrifices
him some but it doesn't even work the
Queen survives so they can have their
big fourth act finale and that's that's
the contradiction of this movie there's
so many awesome things in this movie but
they're executed so poorly that you love
them and you hate them at the same time
of course they bring back a lot of the
other cast members vivica a fox returns
for no reason
they bring through the cave Fox back
literally just to kill her the only
reason I could possibly think why vivica
a fox was in that movie
is that baby that she helps safe and on
the helicopter has got to be the main
character of independence day three when
it comes out in 2036 it reminded me of
San Andreas if the rock hadn't rescued
anybody it's just her son is there
watching her and then she just dies okay
fine whatever we need to talk about judd
hirsch every time they cut to judd
hirsch his storyline got stupider and
stupider and stupider i have no idea why
he agreed to do this movie i have no
idea why they even wrote that storyline
into the movie i think we'd have a nice
little cameo there'd be a little heart
for Jeff Goldblum when his dad gets
killed on the boat but no they decided
to make his storyline the dumbest thing
ever Dom in a roland emmerich movie by
the way that's pretty dumb but let's
talk about my favorite returning
character from the first movie and I'm
shocked to say this it was brent Spiner
as dr. Okun
brent Spiner looks so happy to be in
this movie I don't think anybody told
him that this movie should have come out
in 1998 I don't think anybody told him
that nobody really remembered who his
character was from the first movie he
was the only one that really seemed to
deliver the kind of spirit of the first
movie everyone else seems kind of damp
kind of dull kind of depressed almost to
be in this movie like even though the
first we had some serious moments
everybody there was having fun and brent
Spiner is the only one that seemed to
carry that kind of mentality to this
movie so dr. Okun was my favorite
returning character from the movie why
did they give Oken the best character
development in all the movie there's a
lot of people that could have used a lot
of character development and I love Okin
but Oken wouldn't have been my choice
but there's one guy that I do want to
talk about it was the African warlord
dikembe Ubu too he's played by do BIA
OPI and I hope I'm getting this right
because this guy this actor and this
character forget Independence Day 3 what
we need is the prequel movie about
Dikembe Ubu to fighting aliens on the
ground in Africa for a decade with two
machetes on his back that is cooler than
anything that they put in the rest of
this movie they were hunting us we have
to learn
to hunt them I need predator but with
Independence Day aliens in Africa right
now that script needs to be written
right now I want to see that movie right
now I want to see that more than
anything that they offered an infinite a
resurgence so as you may be able to tell
I don't know what to make of this movie
I don't know if I loved it or hated it I
think both I really felt some love and
some passion and some heart from some of
the stories from some of the characters
the spirit of the original movie in some
ways was still there in some ways it was
the same kind of shallow blockbuster
that we've been getting the last few
summers and that's the reason why it's
not a great movie is because it is half
of the kind of cynical cash grab under
written bland thing that we're so used
to but the other half of the movie has
that heart has that spirit has that love
does what you want from a sequel that
kind of escalates things that takes the
characters that you like and advances
them since I can't give this movie both
an A and an F I'm gonna give it a C and
I will tell you that if you go see it
and if you tweet me or if you say I
hated this movie I totally agree with
you and if you go see it and you go and
you tweet me and say I love this movie I
totally agree with you this is a weird
movie it's one of the weirdest
blockbusters that I've seen it's
everything I wanted and everything I
feared simultaneously so Independence
Day resurgence I don't know so those are
my thoughts on Independence Day
resurgence I want to know what you think
did you like it did you not like it
either way I'll probably agree with you
let me know in the comment section below
I'd love to hear what you thought and
also be sure to tune in to summer movie
report with Dan Morrow every Monday
morning at 11 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
on screen junkies plus we cover all the
big summer movies including ID for two
or ID six or whatever you want to call
this one we love talking movies and we'd
love to have you join us thank you for
watching our spoiler review of
Independence Day resurgence we will not
go quietly into the night we will be
back very soon thanks for watching David
Levinson a Jeff Goldblum like satellite
engineer
don't listen to this get out of town
yes yes not special